since the early second season of the hit
zombie apocalypse drama The Walking Dead
Maggie Reed played by Lauren Cohan was a
staple of the series however in season 9
Maggie left with the relative safety of
the hilltop colony to join up with a
different band of survivors at least
that was the narrative reason for her
absence behind the scenes however
kohan's contract renegotiations for
season 9 hadn't gone the way she'd hoped
Cohan refused to settle for less and she
was written out of the show on this
diamond from walkers
you forget what people do Cohan went on
to star in the ABC Action dramedy
whiskey Cavalier according to Kohan in
spite of early reports that her only
concern was money she already had one
foot out the door before contract
negotiations broke down talking to ew
Cohan mused eight years is a long time
to spend in one character thankfully for
Maggie fans the character was written
off but not killed